Rewrite the following
expression as the product
of positive exponents, and
then evaluate the expression
when x is equal to 2.
So let's do this first part.
They want to rewrite it as a
product of positive exponents.
So they don't like
the fact that we
have this negative
third power and the 5
to the negative second power.
So we want to rewrite those
as negative exponents.
And to do that, we just have
to remember that something
to a negative power is just--
let me write it over here.
If I have x to the
negative two power,
this is the exact
same thing as 1
over x to the
positive two power.
If I have a to the
negative b power,
this is the exact same thing
as 1 over a to the b power.
You can get rid of that
negative by just putting a 1
over this whole thing.
By taking the inverse
of the whole expression,
you can get rid
of that negative.
So let's do that over here. x to
the negative three power, that
is equal to this-- let me
do this in different colors.
x to the negative
third power, that's
the exact same thing as 1
over x to the third power
by definition.
And we're going to multiply that
by 5 to the negative two power.
Well, 5 to the
negative two power.
Same exact thing.
That's the same.
That's the same thing as 1
over 5 to the second power,
or 1 over 5 to the
positive two power.
And then finally, we have
just a straight up x squared.
The exponent is
already positive there.
So, we could just leave
that as times x squared.
So we did the first part.
We rewrote the
following expression
as the product of
positive exponents.
Now let's evaluate
the expression
when x is equal to 2.
So everywhere we see an
x, we should put a 2.
So this becomes 1
over 2 to the-- let
me do the same colors.
This becomes 1 over
2 to the third power
times 1 over 5 squared
times 2 squared.
Every place we saw an x,
we're now putting a 2.
2 to the third power, just
a reminder, that's 2 times
2 times 2.
That is equal to 8.
So this is equal to 1 over
8 times 1 over 5 squared.
5 squared is equal to 5 times
5, which is equal to 25.
So this is equal to 25.
And then we're going to
multiply that times 2 squared.
So 2 squared is 2 times 2,
which is equal to 4, so times 4.
And you could even do
this as times 4 over 1.
And so you multiply
all the numerators.
That's what we do when
we multiply fractions.
You multiply all the
numerators, 1 times 1 times
4 is equal to 4.
And you multiply
the denominators.
8 times 25 is going to be 200.
And then you can simplify this.
The numerator and
the denominator
are both divisible by 4.
Divide the numerator
by 4, you get one.
Divide the denominator
by 4, you get 50.
So this is equal to 1 over 50.
And just so you see,
there's actually
a way to simplify it before
we even got to this stage
over here.
Actually from this stage, we
could have multiplied it out.
Let me just rewrite this thing.
So this product, if we multiply
it out, this 2 squared,
you could view it
as 2 squared over 1.
So if we were to
multiply this out,
the numerator would
have been equal
to 1 times 1 times 2 squared.
2 squared is just 2 times 2.
So it would've been 2
times 2 in the numerator.
We can ignore the 1's, that
doesn't change the value.
And then the denominator would
have been 2 times 2 times 2.
That's what 2 to
the third power is.
2 times 2 times 2
times 5 times 5.
That's what 5 squared is.
And of course multiplying it
by 1 doesn't change this value.
And then it would
have been more obvious
that you could divide the
numerator and denominator by 2
once, you could do
it again, and then
you'd just be left with
1 over 2 times 5 times 5.
And this, of course,
down here is 50.
This is 10 times 5, which is 50.
You would have gotten
the same result.